[Music]
to get started with a cloud translation
API for curl you need AG CP project
which you can setup in the console
enable the Google Cloud translation API
for that project and then create a
service account and download the private
key as Jason you use these credentials
to access Google Cloud api's so be sure
to keep this file secure and out of your
code and public repos
to securely access the credentials from
your project go to the terminal and set
an environment variable to the path of
your service account if you don't yet
have the Cloud SDK installed on your
machine then install and initialize it
instructions are linked below use curl
to make request to the translation
google api is calm and point the curl
command includes jason with the text to
be translated the language to translate
from and the language to translate to
the source and target languages are
identified using the ISO 639 1 codes the
source language is English in this case
en and the target language is Spanish
yes the format of the query is noted as
text for plain text run the curl command
and you should see this as your response
congratulations you have made your first
request with the Cloud translation API
for curl to find out more about the
client libraries or consult translation
basics check out the cloud documentation
you